-Hey, chief.
-[ Gasps ]
-You got a sec?
-Yeah. What's up?
-Look, man, I'm tired of
being just the guy
who points at stuff.
-Right. Uh, well, look, hey,
I wouldn't underestimate
the pointing.
I mean, the way you do it,
it's chilling.
Hit me with it again.
-Boom!
-Aaah! Oh!
You're very good at it.
-Yeah.
I appreciate that,
but I've got some catchphrases
I want to try out.
Check these out.
Welcome to the bone zone.
[ Laughs ]
Bone appétit. Ha!
Or my favorite -- you've been
Christmas Caroled, bitch.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Tracy Morgan.
That was a clip from the new
movie "Spirited."
Very fun take on
the "Christmas Carol" classic.
-Thank you.
-You play a ghost.
Do you believe in ghosts, Tracy?
-Do I believe in ghosts?
-Yeah.
-Only if they got hit by
Walmart trucks.
-Okay, gotcha.
That's Will Ferrell,
your friend Will Ferrell.
-I love Will. Will is my chief.
-You've got a really special
other co-star in the film --
your daughter, Maven.
-Yeah, that's my baby.
That's my stinka-mama.
-That's great.
And did you --
-I love you, Maven.
I love you, Tracy.
Matter of fact,
my daughter and my son
are in the dressing room
right now, man.
-This is Maven right there.
-Yeah, she's doing a backflip
on the red carpet.
-Backflip on the red carpet.
Pretty impressive.
-Yeah.
-Did you teach her how to
backflip, Tracy?
-Absolutely not.
-Okay.
-I keep telling you,
I got hit by a Walmart truck.
-What's Thanksgiving like
at the Morgan house?
-Well, I really don't want to --
My grandmother
usually hosts Thanksgiving.
And she's gonna have my uncle,
who just came home from prison.
He did 38 years in prison.
-Well, that's lovely
to have him back.
-No, it's not.
He's institutionalized.
You know how he says grace?
-How?
-"Yo, thank you, G,
for giving us this life, G.
Yo, thank you for giving us
food, my dude.
Yo, good lookin', G.
Peace, I'm out."
I told my grandmother
"I'm not eating that food.
If y'all eat that food,
somebody going to pass away."
-Do you feel like the
holiday season
has been lost a little bit,
the spirit?
-Yeah, man.
If you look around, man, people
don't put lights up no more.
The only lights in New York City
are the Christmas tree
at Rockefeller Center.
-Yeah, it's true.
-Nobody puts lights up
anymore, man.
-What do you think happened?
-Santa Claus, man.
He wigged out because Mrs. Claus
was cheating on him.
-No.
-Yeah, everybody knows she
was running around with Krampus.
-Oh, no.
-Jack Frost --
she dealt with Jack Frost.
-You have a very --
-No, but Santa Claus
moved to Florida now.
He left the North Pole.
He moved to Florida.
He's dealing with
a lady out there named Carol.
So he's getting happy again.
-Carol?
-Yeah, he's getting
back on his feet.
And Rudolph the Red-Nosed
Reindeer -- his nose is red?
-Yeah.
-That's cocaine.
-No.
-He don't got no cartilage,
no nothing in his nose no more.
-No cart--
The cartilage is gone.
-The cartilage is gone.
-Oh, my God.
-The membrane -- No membrane.
You sneeze,
and the coke boogers came out.
-Hey, you're going the
New York Comedy Festival.
That's very exciting.
This Saturday.
-Yes, I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And, Tracy, even more exciting,
it's your birthday -- today!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we've got a cake
for you, Trace.
Here you go. Happy birthday
to you right there.
And I wanted to get some --
I wanted to get you some
cake toppers.
Now, Tracy, you've long said you
are related to Jacques Cousteau.
-Yes.
-So we got you, you know,
an octopus there and a shark.
You love Shark Week, right?
-Yes, I do.
-Have you seen the
"Star Wars" films, Tracy?
-Yes, and everybody knows
Chewbacca's a bum.
-Okay, why is Chewbacca a bum?
-Everybody knows he's behind in
his child-support payments.
-He is?
-Got 16 puppies out there
he ain't taking care of.
-The Knicks.
You love the Knicks.
-I love my Knicks, baby.
-Fancy sports car.
-Oh, yeah.
I got a couple of those.
-Alright, so, just for time,
I'm gonna light
one of these candles,
and why don't you burn it out --
blow it out, excuse me,
and make a wish for us, Tracy.
-Okay.
My two kids to have good health
and joy and love in their life.
And for all the fans and all
you guys out there in the world,
may God bless you,
and I love you.
-Alright, there we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tracy Morgan, everybody.
"Spirited"
is in theaters tomorrow
and available November 18th
on Apple TV+
We'll be right back with
James Acaster.